the nominees for the best achievement in
directing are Peter cataneo for The Full
Monty Gus Van Zandt Good Will Hunting
Curtis Hanson 408 confidential
Atom Egoyan for the school Iraq
James Cameron for Titanic
the Oscar goes to James Cameron for
Titanic
second Academy Award
tonight's oxygen the best editing mr.
camera is written and or directed nine
through
Nader and the abyss
I don't know about you but I'm having a
really great time every director that
ever stood up here at his cast to thank
and I had a killer cast they really
threw down for me so Kate Gloria
Leo Cathy
Francis and Billy bill Susie Lewis and
about 80 others you guys gave me pure
gold every day and I share this gold
with you everybody else that I was going
to thank got an Oscar or a nomination so
they're covered except for my fellow
producers racing kini and John Landau
Josh McLaughlin rod Lory my brother Mike
Cameron who built the deep diving camera
system my lovely wife Linda our two
beautiful children Dalton and Josephine
and my original producers my parents who
are here tonight Phillip Phillip and
Shirley Cameron mom dad there's no way
that I can express to you what I'm
feeling right now my heart is full to
bursting except to say on the K the
world
you